If you completed all those exercises
then you're well on your way to
understanding how Turing machines
compute and hopefully also are ready to
be convinced that they can compute as
well as any other possible machine.
Before we move onto that argument
however there's some terminology
about Turing machines and
the languages that they accept and
reject and those that they might
loop on that we should set straight.
Some of the terms may seem similar, but
the distinctions are important ones, and
we'll use them freely throughout
the rest of the course so
pay close attention.
>> First, we define what it means for
a machine to decide a language.
We say a Turing machine decides
a language L if it accepts every string
in the language and it rejects
every string not in the language.
For example, the Turing machine we
just described decided the language L
consisting of strings of the form
w#w where w was a binary string.
We also might say that the Turing
machine computed the function
that is 1 is X is in the language and
0 otherwise.
Or even just that the Turing machine
computed the language at all.